Y todas y todos tenemos el deber de darle caucín
como ganadores de las elecciones.
Trataré de conformar 1 gobierno
que esté formado por mujeres y hombres de solvencia
contrastada. Y lo haré porque sus personas,
esas personas,
deberán
Dar respuesta a los retos que enfrentará Euskadi
en 1 futuro cercano.
Defenderé los intereses de toda la ciudadanía vasca.
1 sociedad vasca a la que me debo,
nos debemos por encima de todo.
Han confiado de manera mayoritaria en nuestro proyecto.
Han confiado de manera mayoritaria en nuestra propuesta.
No hay mayor honor
y mayor responsabilidad.
Con humildad, con trabajo,
daré todo por Euskadi,
todos y cada 1 de los días.
¡Es qué Rica estoy!